yvon s'excuse aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur ce coup qui leur volent violent cave
aux [ __ ] plus loin encore le citron
anglais s'il vous plaît c'est un jeu
d'horreur mais très particulier
attention parce qu'apparemment il fait
pop pas si peur que ça après il est vrai
qu'on n'a pas trop de courage donc même
si les sentais pas trop faire peur nous
sommes en jeu c'est un petit peu un
salut je suis ce pot qui salue fauqué à
la belle chevelure transparente
voilà c'est tout ça va me dire ah non
c'est ma maison oui pouvez-vous un bleu
player aller à travers des centaines de
chambres des centaines de chambres quoi
que ça va durer combien de temps mais
vous savez quoi
on n'est pas des [ __ ] bref vas-y
alors c'est du coup il faut juste aller
au travers de mariage et de barre
d'énergie il faut aller au travers
toutes les chambres c'est sa chambre un
et chambres deux déjà ok d'accord il
faut que j'aie l'attrait des centaines
de chambres comme ça puisque chez ben's
avait sa maman quatre mille ans plus
tard on n'est qu'à la chanteuse option
qu'on a fait 6 ans forment déjà pu
interroger ou pas n'ont toujours pas où
des femmes s'étaient fait beau comme
vous avez vu oui écouter offerts on
s'amuse comme on peut
voilà le montrent il va nous mettre en
extase total aux [ __ ] boys et carbon
serré quoi ça fait mal argent quoi c'est
vous dire à quel point c'est sérieux pas
tel un chat ça vient l'escrimeur
électrique d'horaires nous sommes
maintenant un champ 26 et vous savez
quoi
il ne sait toujours rien passé merci
lucas pour cette information maintenant
notre flash spécial c'est des draps qui
des housses de couette qui vole un accès
très peur et qu'on arrivait chez 90 ça
va être la folie c'est la fête je vous
promets on appelle patrick sébastien en
direct à au début cette place départ est
mignonne mais ça fait bien un jour que
je suis ici maintenant je me sens un peu
par shed et je me sens observé par
quelque chose ce n'est pas du tout
romantique et m'a très bien
c'est peut-être ce petit bonhomme vert
ouais bon gars c'est quoi ça oh j'ai
sauvegardé
oui c'est on peut mourir ouais mais pas
comment on va mourir quoi il va nous
étouffe et danseurs dans son corps je
l'éthique je laisse des notes à quelques
endroits parce que ça prouve que je suis
en train de progresser vers une
certaines destinations
une petit claque sur les fesses on saura
donc le budget ça c'est juste à l'est de
chambre en chambre et des fois il ya une
sympathie qui se passe un truc puisque
tu es dans la bonne voie alors des fois
tu glisses sur une flaque d'huile et
humains aussi ça arrive à une note mon
dieu jaillissement éclaboussures
trempage entrailles ingère invoquant
clouage jamais arrêté l'étouffement et
on dit merci [ __ ] de google traduction
mon dieu je m'en vais plutôt qu'elle
était
fox a ralenti respect va chier tout
élève to the left et norman gestion
jeter un hareng et j'en ai maire a salué
lui chante avec moi ça alors tourner
avant et ça m'énerve car elle a été
punie au coin ici tu bad quand même un
centimètre de la mort on sait qu'un jour
on va arriver au bout du jeu face aux
simples là je n'ai qu'un but dans ma vie
à l'heure actuelle un très gros buts
attention fini à ce [ __ ] de jeu 190
tous se lèvent tout seul est monsieur
cerveau ou poulpe monsieur cerveau à
tentacules c'est un réel plaisir de
rencontrer j'insiste mais je rentre un
méchant aussi gros school où l'odeur
n'est pas un truc là genre le couloir
infini bons fous je suis têtu alors tu
vas voir au moi j'ai bien fait d'être
têtu [ __ ] vous voit souvent imagées si
elle fait demi-tour et ben on va vers le
vert la lumière qu'on a perdu mais on
est dans des eaux
on est tombé dans un [ __ ] de pièces
jamais nulle part c'est une [ __ ]
d'illusions d'optiques de magicien la de
sorcier un oeil à ce reproche de 50
grâce à la sauvegarde au fédéral de juin
monde aurait plus que 7e bca centaines
ah il approuve également mondiaux
chambre au saut à vous ne venez pas
pourquoi j'ai dû véhicule est assez
évident rim s'est réveillé il a trouvé
une bouteille de vin derrière lui wiseid
13 euros il n'est pas sûr de l'année du
20 août son label mais en tout cas il
dit que ça avait un fort goût métallique
c'est pas du tout intéressant lorsqu'on
veut se barrer
l'enregistrement du jeu c'était encore
arrêtée alors là un gros nez on a trouvé
un pc dans lequel il donne une
indication sur tous les monstres qu'on
trouve dans le jeu a par exemple à indy
erreur nickel voilà on leur connaît un
qui nous volent et qui finit bien à elle
qui fait un peu flipper quand même on
peut le dire à attendre mais d'où tu
fais ce bruit quoi de plus sensé faire
un bruit comme je peins je suis me
dionne a récemment sorti j'ai vu dans le
dans l'ordinateur
menacé d'un tunisien en fait c'est un
monstre donc le sujet numéro 5 grossit
plus voilà j'ai dit à spock on a besoin
de plus de sédatifs mais la juste rigolé
je sais pas combien de temps pourra
encore les garder ici de manière
sécurisée on ne tient d'accès seul
braley la wii aux notes je crois qu'on a
perdu le sujet 5
c'est ça c'est ça sa conclusion à yahr
oui il ya un mois la tension et 60 rue
court plus tard oh ça m'excite [ __ ]
enfin il se passe un truc bordel à mon
dieu il est nouveau mais lui tout mignon
voire était encore 4e mais on est à
l'aso 50 cent cinquante
oui c'est l'heure de la soupe ce n'est
pas une blague
elle votera
les croûtons guys who played quoique
j'ai comme plein vidéo
il se laisse un petit souk hockey au
nouveau décor ça fait plaisir c'est ce
que je me dis les trois premières
chambres environ
j'envoie 160 un homme vers m'attaque et
mon coeur s'enflamme
j'en ressors 65 je possède une flash
lite je n'ai jamais fait ça pour le
moment je suis heureux mais sans trop
l'être non plus c'est déjà fini
on nous ça recommence pardon jambes 200
milles
j'ai 85 ans et je suis toujours à
travers cette vidéo mon cerveau est
actuellement décédé je ne fais plus
aucune réaction face à ce qui m'entoure
lambres 190 je trouve une note je ne
pense pas que c'était du vin
[ __ ] une seconde note je ne sais pas
combien de temps je vais encore pouvoir
faire ça je n'ai vu aucune des
précédentes notes ça veut bien dire que
je suis en train d'aller quelque part ou
alors que quelqu'un a pris les notes
chambre 199 j'arrive enfin à la chambre
de sens je pense que c'est ma dernière
note g mourir avant d'avoir trouvé la
sortie
il nous reste cinq chambres à faire
environ et c'est la fin du jeu c'est pas
du tout j'ai pas crier puisque tu étais
là déjà j'ai créé parce que je sais pas
j'avais envie de faire à et parra ça
devient très bizarre oh mon dieu
une femme nue m'approche au wat via le
fup match moyen ça va être une sorte de
mons qui m'attaquent
du coup je ne vois plus rien vous
déteste tous lui qui arrive désormais à
la chambre de 150 ooo il se passe un
truc donc tu l'as fait oui je les fais
c'est c'est bien oui je devrais te
donner un cadeau pour ton progrès donc
tient juste prend le mais en plus elle
est tout mignon avec [ __ ] oui je le
prends avec grand plaisir
regarde derrière toi
oh ça faisait tellement et maintenant
sauvegarde aulas confesse une histoire
de courage c'est un petit peu comme ta
journée d'appel le plus chiant encore
que ta journée d'appel sauf que là tout
le monde tu peux quitter alors ta
journée d'appel continuer si elle est
suffisamment s'en échappe pour tous nous
libérer comme ça mais non nous devons y
arriver j'ai entrevu à traire mes gros
doigts bien gras qui me gratter le nez
quoi ou en os au melia une fanfare
jambes 300 j'ai sauvegardé
c'est toujours pas fini mais si je
pouvais me pète et le froid sur cette
croix je le ferai j'en peux plus et la
fois pour aujourd'hui les joueurs
j'espère que ça vous au lait c'est pas
mal ce sont 300 déjà n'hésitait pas aimé
la vidéo parce qu'on a été très
courageux je trouve qu'on ait beaucoup
de courage c'est important on peut plus
c'est incroyable et c'est un bus le jeu
était fait pour ça
testé mais ce que je veux dire bon allez
c'est pas un élève de l sabonnères si
vous voulez co co content d'aller plus
loin beaucoup plus loin même je dirais
personnes regardent et déjà tout le
monde
pis
r